bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous qu'est-ce que tu chopes
hayden attend de ce g7 qui débutera
vendredi
l'objectif principal c'est évidemment de
réaffirmer laideur chip américain et
dans le fond ça ne sera pas si simple
que cela puisque donald trump avait
horreur de ce genre de réunions qu'ils
soient se passer balle soit le voyez
relativement discret comme à biarritz
lorsque la france présidé le g7 et
l'année dernière il a carrément passer
son tour
c'était aux états unis de présider un
gsm et après avoir proposé de le tenir à
marée de la gauche c'est-à-dire chez lui
près de son terrain de golf puis à quand
des villes il a dû renoncer la
chancelière ayant dit que le coc vie de
finalement faisait qu' elles ne
pourraient pas se déplacer
donc il y faut réaffirmer son leadership
et pour cela il va d'abord prendre des
moyens qui sont les sujets consensuels
naturellement le réchauffement
climatique puisqu'il a réintroduit les
états unis dans l'accord de paris et
qu'il est sincèrement convaincu qu'il
faut en effet lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique il en va de
l'avenir de la planète
et puis la vaccination alors il va il va
certainement affirmé qu' il faut
maintenant vaccinée le monde évidemment
ces nouveaux puisque comme d'autres pays
il a d'ailleurs donné la priorité à ses
compatriotes aux américains et tous les
vaccins fabriqués sur le territoire
américain ont été consacrés à la
vaccination des américains donc
aujourd'hui et il commence à prendre des
mesures pour à travers le dispositif de
l' oms de donner des vaccins de faire en
sorte que les pays les plus pauvres
puissent disposer de vaccins pour le
moment les engagements les états unis
sont inférieurs à ceux de l'union
européenne et pour vacciner la terre
entière il faudrait évidemment les
milliards de vaccins qui pour le moment
ne peuvent pas être produit car il n'y a
pas les capacités industrielles dans le
monde
donc peut-être discuterons t-il de cela
comment faire pour faire en sorte que de
développer ses capacités industrielles
et monter des task force pour ce que en
effet les vaccins soient disponibles
pour tout le monde
c'est d'ailleurs à cette seule condition
on que la pandémie s'arrêtera je pense
qu'il prendra aussi oui oui je pense
qu'il essaiera aussi de renforcer ce que
les ministres des finances du g7 ont
discuté hongrie ont conclu un accord
dimanche dernier c'est en effet une
novation considérable puisqu'il
s'agirait de taxer les grandes
multinationales qui pour le moment
peuvent localiser leurs bénéfices un peu
là où elles le veulent et évidemment
optimiser leur leurs paiements fiscaux
c'est-à-dire les minimiser en réalité
donc si le g7 confirme ce que les mises
des finances ont conclu eh bien il
faudra ensuite convaincre le g20
ensuite convaincre l'ouest c'est l' ocde
et ensuite effectivement mettre en place
ce dispositif
ça ne sera pas très simple mais c'est
courageux de sa part de vouloir essayer
est toujours avec nous donc claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales claude
bon gré mal gré le projet de ce gazoduc
nord stream 2 va donc voir le jour
pourquoi les etats-unis ont-ils
finalement changé de position il n'y a
que de bonnes nouvelles en ce qui
concerne leur cm2 puisque en effet le
livre d'un feu mais l'administration
américaine a décidé de lever les
sanctions qui s'appliquait à l'égard de
l'entreprise qui construit et north
stream 2 et à partir de ce moment les
travaux ont pu reprendre pendant le
forum de saint pétersbourg
il a été annoncé que la première ligne
de nord stream ii était achevée que les
travaux sur la deuxième ligne se
poursuivait et serait achevée nos trois
mois donc en effet c'est la chancelière
merkel qui l'a emporté avec son calme et
sa détermination habituelle puisque 100
employés de grands mots et là avec une
grande constance développer son
argumentation
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires de l'union
européenne et vis-à-vis des américains
et finalement elle l'a emporté son
argumentation est très simple
l'allemagne a renoncé au nucléaire pour
fabriquer l'électricité elle s'est
engagée à renoncer au charbon et à
décarbonés complètement son industrie
par conséquent et il n'y aura plus de
centrales à charbon en 2038 les énergies
renouvelables ne suffiront pas à combler
le déficit il faut donc du gaz
et effectivement c'est assez logique de
prendre de gaz russe puisque c'est sur
le même continent il peut être amené à
boncourt avons pris par des
infrastructures fixes et coûter moins
cher par conséquent que le gaz liquéfié
qui viendrait des états unis d'amérique
ou ou d'ailleurs où le golfe et par
conséquent c'est ce qui va se produire
alors bien entendu on a toujours dit et
beaucoup de pays ont toujours dit qu'il
fallait garantir les recettes que le
transit au curé à l'ukraine puisqu'il ya
un gazoduc qui continuera de fonctionner
bien sûr il n'est pas question de le
remplacer traverse l'ukraine et il faut
qu'ils aient une discussion
donc comme l'a dit monsieur lavrov il y
a une obligation maintenant de discuter
entre la russie les européens et
l'ukraine et tant mieux puisque plus on
discutera entre sais pas ces trois
partenaires mieux ça vaudra et club dont
je fais en vont retrouver pour la
dernière fois pour évoquer
tous ces thèmes qui ponctuent qui vont
ponctuer cette tournée américaine la
première de joe biden le sénat américain
a donc adopté hier un texte qualifié
d'historique pour contrer pékin des
états unis ne vont pas s'arrêter là
je crois que le texte en effet adopté
par le congrès est très important 170
milliards de dollars pour la recherche
la recherche fondamentale la recherche
appliquée et pour éviter que que la
chine presse une elles prennent une
avance déterminante sur les dents les
nouvelles technologies je crois que
d'ailleurs que l'europe ferait bien de
s'inspirer de cet exemple
cela dit monsieur biden a souvent dit et
les américains disent depuis un certain
temps son prédécesseur le disait aussi
que la chine est beaucoup plus qu'un
concurrent
c'est un rival systémique c'est à dire
que le système chinois est antinomique
des systèmes américain et settat rival
systémiques et en plus à des velléités
de contrôler les zones de trafic
maritime
que ce soit à l'est de la chine entre la
chine et le japon
que ce soit en asie du sud est c'est ce
qu'on appelle la mer de chine du sud
et puis évidemment dans le détroit de
taiwan et vous venez vous venez d'en
parler là il ya évidemment pour tous les
pays occidentaux d'ailleurs un élément
tout à fait essentiel le maintien de la
liberté de navigation dans tout cédé 3
et dans toutes ces mères puisqu'une
grande partie du trafic de marchandises
du monde entier passent par ces détroit
et par ses hôtes
donc je crois que en effet les états
unis ont entrepris d'utiliser sans doute
taïwan comme contrepoids réchauffer
leurs relations avec taiwan de façon à
dire à la chine attention mais il ya une
limite c'est celle que vous avez
indiquée dans votre sujet tous les pays
qui ont des relations diplomatiques avec
pékin ont reconnu qu'il n'y avait qu'une
seule chine et qu'il ne pouvait pas
avoir de relations diplomatiques avec
taipei peuvent entretenir des relations
économiques et des relations culturelles
les etats-unis traditionnellement et se
considère comme responsable de la
défense de taiwan
mais il ya une ligne
dépassés sinon effectivement pékin ne
l'accepterai pas alors ce sujet va sans
doute être adopté et être évoqué au g7
une bonne surprise il a été ménagé
monsieur byden c'est que le deuxième
jour il va retrouver autour de la table
les invités de monsieur godden solde de
monsieur boris johnson qui sont le
premier ministre indien qui sont le
premier le président sud coréen
le premier ministre australien est
également le président sud africain
ces quatre pays font partie de ce que
les think tanks américains appellent une
éventuelle initiative indo pacifique
c'est à dire une ceinture plus ou moins
formalisées qui serait destiné à
contenir la chine
d'ailleurs il y à quelques quelques
semaines il ya environ deux mois le
président by dell avait pris
l'initiative d'un sommet entre lui même
et certains des dirigeants de ce pays le
premier ministre japonais le premier
ministre indien est le premier ministre
australien
il ya donc en effet là quelque chose qui
probablement va provoquer une discussion
au pendant pendant le pendant le g7
discussions sur la façon la meilleure
façon de prendre le problème chinois
avec ces pays ces pays ne sont pas tous
désireux d'avoir une alliance formalisé
l'inde par exemple est très très très
très heureux sans doute d'avoir des
relations plus fortes avec les états
unis mais elle ne veut pas d'une
alliance militaire quelle réelle veut
conserver les bonnes relations avec la
chine
et il en va de même d'ailleurs de la
corée du sud
il veut pas aggraver les tensions avec
la corée du nord par ailleurs les
américains ont fait savoir déjà dans le
passé qu'il comptait sur d'autres pays
qui ne sont pas particulièrement
démocratique pour contenir la chine par
exemple vietnam donc il est probable que
ce concept indo pacifique qui est encore
assez floue se précisera peut-être sous
diverses formes dans l'est dans l'est
dans les mois et dans les années
merci claude blanche maison